when Ravens carried the news of aegon's
Coronation to Dragonstone princess
rhaenyra summoned her own black Council
with her was her uncle and husband Damon
Targaryen considered by many to be the
most dangerous man in Westeros
few Lords supported her but the greatest
of these was Corliss Valerian who
controlled the largest Fleet in the
realm and his Targaryen wife rhaenys the
old King's sister then there were her
five Sons although none grown to manhood
a pitiful assembly really combined they
couldn't match the power of house
Hightower alone but rhaenyra had dragons
she Damon and rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
Sons were Riders as well
Dragonstone also housed six more Dragons
without Riders against this King aegon
had only four dragons of his own
dragons can burn a city
but only armies can take and hold it if
she was to Prevail Rainier had
desperately needed the support of the
few great houses not already sworn to
aegon
her eldest son jacaris flew to the veil
in the north a middle son lucaris flew
to the stormlands rhaenyra hoped that
the war would begin and if the gods were
good end with diplomacy
as always they weren't
Little Prince Lou Caris must have wet
himself when he entered Storm's end and
found King aegon's younger brother
Eamonn already with Lord Baratheon
Eamonn was fearsome even before he lost
his eye and set a sapphire in its stead
but the princeling pleaded his mother's
case finally Lord Baratheon made his
decision go on pop and tell the [ __ ]
your mother that the Lord of Storm's end
is not a dog she can whistle up as
eamonn's false eye gleamed at him the
princeling fled the castle and mounted
his young dragon arax the rain fell in
sheets and great bolts of lightning lit
the world bright as day
arax was struggling to stay aloft in the
Gale when a raw shook the very
foundations of Storm's end
Eamonn grows through the clouds and
Below him the Monstrous Vega Vega was
five times the size of arax and the
hardened Survivor of a hundred battles
vegar called him above shipbreaker Bay
watches on the castle walls saw distant
blasts of flame and heard a shriek drown
out the Thunder
Prince Lucas fell broken to be swallowed
by the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of Fire and Blood began
when rhaenyra heard of her son's death
she collapsed
she considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
Damon her son would be Avenged
for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire Targaryen history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using her Link in the
description
foreign